Mark: Hello  everybody my name is Markiplier and welcome to Stikbold, a dodge ball adventure.
Mark/Wade: Hi.
Mark: We actually have dodge balls.
Mark: Oh sorry, did you mean to say hi-
*Mark&Wade Laughing*
Bob: I was too slow, I-I missed it. * Mark and Wade laugh*
Wade: Too slow!
Mark: The window comes by and goes, the Markiplier window-
Bob: Hi, hi!
Mark: There is no second chances.
Bob: I'll be ready next time
Mark: There's not gonna be next time
Bob: Ok!
*Mark/Wade laughing*
Bob: What?
Mark: Are we just going...?
Wade: I-
Mark: Oh. | Bob: Oh,
Wade: Wait which-
All: What?
Mark: Oh, that was the intro movie!
Wade/Bob: Oh, okay
*All Laughing Hysterically *
Mark: How many games have we played?
Mark: Wow!
Bob: What?
Bob: I am second player!
Mark: I am no~t in this!
Bob: Keyboard and mouse is also a player
Wade: That's good-
Mark: NOOO
*Bob/Wade Laughing*
Mark: I am blue!
Mark: I am Björn!
Bob: I'm red, that seems terribly wrong.
Wade: I'm Jero- yeah it is.
Mark: Tough, you'll have to deal with it.
Mark: I don't even know how to play, how we gonna go?
Wade: Do you want bots?
Mark: Yeah~ *Increasing in pitch*
Mark: One, ridiculously difficult bot.
Bob: What?
Wade: Huh.
Mark: Do it!
Bob: Why?
Wade: Alright.
Mark: Oh, she looks sassy-
Bob: Oh god she looks terrifying.
Wade: And we're going to play-
Mark: Random?
Mark/Bob: Hell.
Mark: Yes!
Wade: Okay.
Mark: Why would they play dodgeball in hell?
Wade: Oh I didn't look at points to win, so who knows what we--
Bob: I think it said three.
Mark: Okay
Bob: Alright so we got two hats, or, somethin'.
*Overlapping shouts of confusion*
Bob: I'm a, I'm a, I'm a goddamn edge ghost
Wade: How does she dive?
Mark: Ow!
Wade: Okay let's dive, left trigger is dive.
Mark: *Continuing to whine like a baaaaaby*
Wade: *Insert gorilla speech text*
Bob: Why, did you put on a hard bot??
Wade: Ah! She's diving at me!
Mark: Why does the angel playing music in hell?
Wade: *Screams*
Mark: *giggling at Wade's flailing*
Wade: Nu nu nu- Aahhaa!
Mark: Oh nohohohoho!
Wade: It was his decision.
Mark: *High pitched* What are you looking at me for?!
Bob: *Quoting Mark* "Put on, a really fuckin' difficult bot!"
Bob: *Still Quoting Mark* "That'll be fun!"
Mark/Wade: *Mating calls*
Mark: Do we have to press a button to grab it?
Wade: *Insert chimpanzee speech text*
Wade: Don't let it touch me, don't let it touch me.
Mark: He~y!
Mark: Oho, I got it!
Wade: *grunts wildly*
Mark: Hup!
Bob: Oh, God!
Mark: Ah ha!
Wade: *more weird grunting*
Wade: Ye~aga!
Wade: Kapow!
Bob: Oh he fucking bounced it on me!
Wade: *single, high-pitched grunt*
Bob: I didn't get- fuck you guys!
Mark: Haha!
Wade: Oh, ahh!
Mark: Haha, haha!
Wade: No, no, no!
Mark: He~y!
Wade: Oh into the lava!
Wade: Did you win?
Mark: Ahahahaha! I did!
Mark: It's left trigger and right trigger.
Mark: Right trigger to grab left ti- trigger to drive.
Mark: Dive, dip-
Mark: *Ecstasy*
Wade: *Seal yawning*
Bob: Oh shit!
Wade: *High pitched wail* Ah skeleton, it's a skeleton on me!
Wade: Ah~! Get it off me! Ow!
Bob: God, f~ucking dammit!
Mark: *Laughing in the dark pit of loneliness and depression that'll never see the light of day*
Wade: No no no no no, nwa~!
Bob: This bot is so annoying!
Bob: Fucking fuck you Bot. God dammit!
Wade: Gimme the ball! Wha~, d-no-don't give me the ball!
Mark: What!? Lava!?
Wade: *Chuckling to himself*
Mark: What!?
Mark: *Cries in depression*
Bob: Oh god- shit!
Wade: Uh oh- *cry of agony* eh.
Mark: You got it Bob, you got Bob.
Mark: Nice!
Wade: Get Her Bob, Oh Bob, you got her.
Wade: Don't dive in the lava Bob.
Mark: don't die- *Maniacal giggling *
Wade: Whe~ oh, th-that was almost her, Bob
Wade: Uh Oh
Bob: Oh no no no, the lava!
Mark: What'd we tell you?
Bob: I thought that it was gonna be shorter than the lava.
Wade: Wha-
Mark: Ughh..
Wade: Well that was-
Mark: Wha- what are we playing to- what kind of-
Bob: She wins! She fucking wins.
Mark: oh, Yeah!!
Mark: Go- *starts clapping*
Mark: You gotta be happy for people every once in a while.
Bob: That's not a person!
Mark: Oh.*Laughs*
Mark: *uncontrollable giggling*
Bob: It's not- It's not a person is it? *Mark continues to die on the inside*
Mark: Noo.
Bob: Okay.
Bob: Why you laughing like that?
Mark: (muffled laughter) I don't know!
Mark: Alright so now we're gonna play for real.
Mark: Not against a Bot, we're still learning. We're going to be very forgiving on each other.
Mark: And uh-
Mark: it's gonna be a fun time.
Wade: Let's start here?
Mark: Yeah, let's start here, basic stuff.
Bob: the gym seems like the place for Dodge Ball. | Wade: "Basics."
Mark: Mhm.
Bob: I'm red again.
Mark: Yeehaw.
Bob: Me Carsten.
Wade: I'm still green.
Mark: Alright. I'm still blue!
Wade: I'm the first one out and the last one to leave.
*Miscellaneous noises*
Bob: Fuck!
Bob: I dove to try and fucking catch it.
*More miscellaneous noises*
Wade: Aw c'mon-
Bob: Aw Geez.
Wade: I had perfect aim.
Mark: Aw~a!
Bob: C'mon!
Mark: Yay
Wade: He's a bot-
Bob: Jesus Christ!
Mark: Guys, I-
Mark: I'm doing really good guys!
Wade: You're not a person.
Mark: I feel-
Wade: (whispers) You're a bot.
Bob: That's really harsh man.
Mark: (laughing) Yeah!
Bob: Whats wrong with you, Wade?
Mark: "You're just a Bot."
Mark: Hah! AAAAAAAH!
Bob: Gotcha!
Bob: Aw shit, nope, shit!
Wade: Got rid of em!
Mark: Eih, ow ahh ahh!
Mark: "Got rid of me"..?
Wade: yeah, got rid of him.
Mark: That's pretty harsh dude...
Bob: How you doing Wade?
Wade: Good, how you doing?
Bob: Having a good time?
Mark: Wait, what can I do?
Everyone: OHHHHHHHHH!
Mark: I'M COMING FOR YOU!!
Bob: WHAT THE FUCK!
Mark: Whe~!
Bob: Goddamn it!
Mark: Did you guys see me?
Wade: No, what'd you do?
Mark: I came back!
Wade: Oh no!
Mark: On a floor washer!!
Bob: Oh, weird.
Mark: Yeah, didn't you guys notice me riding a floor washer?
Wade: Oh, was that you coming after us?
Mark: Yeah!
Wade: Oh we all missed it!
Mark: There's like a- there's like a, unique bounce.
Bob: Are there no other- are there no other buttons for this?
Bob: No I fucking dodged!
*Wade grunting*
Wade: Oh hey.
Mark: Wha~yaya.
Wade: Ow, come on! Nope- *Endangered species grunting for hope*
Mark: Ehehehe, awhaha!
Mark: Wait, did you just throw a hot dog?
Bob: I did.
Mark: Where'd you... what?!
Bob: If you- if you dive at the hot-dog cart-
Bob: FUCK YOU!! (Simultaneous incomprehensible speaking, mostly cursing)
Wade: Wha~, did I just kamikaze into you?
Bob: God! Jesus Christ! I'm so mad right now!
Mark: *Laughing*
Wade: I think- I think my guy just got naked and charged in at you!
Mark: Yeah that's what happens.
Mark: you, like, when your dead you can come back and interfere with people.
Wade: (Sudden epiphany)Oh, I like dying now.
Bob: Oh, jeez..
Mark: Ha!
Wade: What!?
Mark: OH it just interrupts, ahaha!
Wade: How did you get a hot dog- Oh you gotta go up to her?
Mark: Yeah. Hey, lemme see what is -AH! Oh I was just gonna see-
Wade: ah haha you got waxed!
Mark/Wade: *Laughing*
Bob: Oh my God... Jesus Christ.
Bob: So it actually kills?
Mark/Wade: YEAH!
Wade: I think I killed you in the game before.
Mark: Wow
*All grunting*
Mark: Owwww. He's on a mission!
*More grunts*
Wade: *very high-pitched* "Ah, BOB!"
Bob: Oh my god!
Bob: Ho~ly shit
Mark: *Grunts* Uh oh...
Mark: Aha!
Mark: AH, ma butt!
Wade: You guys better look out, here I come!
Wade: Woo Hooo!
Mark: Oh no.
Mark: Eh! Eh! Gonna grab ma butt?
Bob: Fucking, how do you do that?
Mark: Right trigger, just right trigger.
Wade: Look out!
Wade: Here comes whiny(?) *Laughing?*
Bob: Oh my god
Bob: You can get it Mark, I'll let you have it.
Mark: Alright.
Wade: Whoooo
Mark: whoops, AH NO!
Wade: I love you!
* Mark repeats NO as Wade repeats "I love you!"*
*laughter as Mark's "no"s get louder*
*laughter*
Mark: WADE
Bob: Were you just fuckin' on him?
Mark: He just grabbed onto my balls!
*immense laughter*
Mark: I couldn't move!
Mark: Piece of crap!
*grunting* Mark: ah! no~!
*Wade becomes gorilla*
Mark:No!
Wade: AH BOB!! NO!
Bob: Oh my god. That pro SHOT THO!
Mark: oh that pro shot.
Bob: God fucking dammit.
Wade: YESS
Bob: FUCK YOU!
Wade: It's tied, it's two to two to two.
Mark: I was coming in for the interference with the love hug.
Wade: Oh, I know. I had to get there fast.
Mark: Alright, it's all tied up.
Wade: Next point wins.
Mark: ah aah ah!
Wade: oh come on? what!
Wade: NOOO!
Wade: Eueheuheu
Bob: Fucking shit. NO. Fuck you guys.
Mark: YEAH
Bob: God DAMNIT
Wade: *Grunts* Eh no!
Mark: WOooooOOoOohoho
Wade: Did you die??
Mark: No, I hit the hot dog man! His cart exPLOded! *Wade laughs*
Mark: and then my cover was gone and you hit me.
Wade: THE COMEBACK!
Mark: eeahh whatever!
Wade: I don't think I hit you, I think you were already dead from the cart.
Mark: Boooo.
Wade: EAH
Bob: Oh
Mark: heh!
Bob: fucking Christ
Wade:EUAH
Wade: AHH CAR!
*Mark's laughter*
Wade: Oh, I thought that was me that got hit
That was Mark- AH BOB!
Bob: God jeez! If I dodge before you shoot...
Bob: ...I die.
Wade: I got you with bees- AHHH
Mark: Incoming!
Bob: I hate you so much.
Wade: AHH the bees got me to- op! *
Bob: I hate all of you, SO MUCH!
Mark: I'm sorry, Bob.
Wade: I didn't know, I was
Mark: Dat was not me though, I did not bee.
Bob: YOU BEES'D ME!
Wade: I bees'd you
Mark: he bees'd you!
Bob: WHAT THE FUCK!
Wade: *laughing* there were just bees on the ground, so I went for them
Bob: *sighs*
*screams from everyone*
Mark: OHHH why every time?
Wade: AH BOB AH
Wade: nonono
Bob: see?? it's fucking im-
Bob: Oh, wha- They don't stick to you??!!
Mark: Hey guys.
Bob: OF COURSE NOT
Mark: I got ya!
Mark: I got ya! oh no, you're coming with me
*Wade screams*
*more screams from Bob and Wade while Mark laughs*
Bob: Oh just come ere! I fucking hit myself!
*Mark laughs*
Bob: Fuck this
*Wade groans*
Bob: How did you-
Wade: I don't know
Mark: How is Wade destroying us?
Mark: This is a bunch of crap.
Wade: I feel really bad about the bees.
Mark: Oh shut up.
Mark: I got you though with the thing.
Wade: I figured - I didn't know if this was a second ball, or if it was actually fake until I grabbed it.
Mark: Ahh! Bees! I bees'd myself!
Mark: Beeeees!
Mark: *Screaming*
Wade: *Laughing*
Mark: No! Cmon!
Mark: I didn't have a chance!
Bob: Oh thank god.
Wade: No no no no!
Bob: Oh my god!
Wade: Right in the balls!
Mark: Oh ho ho.
Bob: Jesus that's my only hope is to avoid
Bob: you assholes until there's only one left.
*Mark and Wade laughs*
Bob: Every time I go into the fight, I get FUCKED!
*Mark and Wade starts laughing again*
All of them: *Grunting*
Mark: AH! ok...
Wade: WAAA! WAAA!
Mark: Hit him!
Wade: AHHH!
Wade: The ca- aww...
Mark: The comeback that was just...
Wade: I was gonna say the car. *Giggles*
Mark: Oh, okay.
Bob: Ah shit! Oh god the fuckin-
Mark: BEES!
Bob: I don't understa- EH OH NO! OH GOD!
Mark: Just try it, Just try it!
Mark: OW! I-
Wade: I don't even know!
Mark:The Bees!
Wade: Finish it Bob!
Bob: OH NO! JESUS NO!
Mark: AHHHH!!
Mark: BEES!
*All of them start laughing*
Bob: Why didn't you get bees?
Mark: I though tha- Yo-you got bees
Bob: I did but you walked into it!
Mark: I thought bees were done!!
Bob: *Laughing*
Mark: It's uh- Its logical to conclude that the bees would be done when you got beesed!
Wade: Oh my god...
Mark: Alright...
Wade: WAH! WOOH!
Bob: Oh, the bees OH THE BEES BEES BEES!!!
Bob: FUCKING GOD DAMMIT!
Wade: AH!
Wade: Well... I don't want the bees- AH!
Mark: Aha!
Bob: Wait, so after the bees hit me that time, they went away.
Bob: I don't understand why they hate you
Bob: OH THEIR TIME!!
Mark: NOOOOO!
Bob: Oh my god... Oh shi- shit SHIT!
Wade: *Grunts*
Mark: It all comes down to this, here comes the goose!
Wade: WHAT!? THE GOOSE!? AHH THE GOOSE!! WAAAA!!
Wade: *Grunting* Bob: OH MY GOD!
*All starts laughing*
Wade: All I could do was scream the goose!!
Bob: That was lucky.
Mark: You gotta imagine like, people playing dodgeball and having a good time, Ha ha- OH got ya!
Mark: *Imitates car running someone over*
Bob and Wade: *Laughing*
Mark: OH NOO!!
Wade: I was up 2 to nothing and Bob came back... and stole it.
Bob: Dude the strategy is just to stay away from everyone else.
Mark: Why are we naked?
Wade: I don't know, I was wondering that too.
Mark: Oh we're at-
Wade: We're at the beach.
Bob: Ah it's beach time
Mark: Alright, you've- you've- you've won one, You've won one, I gotta win one.
Bob: Mark's turn.
Mark: My- my turn, let me win guys.
Wade: Uhh uh oh, uh oh, uh oh.
Bob: Oh shit the crab, it's a crab, it's a CRAB! AH!
Bob: God damn it! The fuckin- How do I- *Screaming*
Wade: OH GOD!
Mark: Nnnooo!
Wade: AH HAH!
Mark and Wade: *Grunting*
Wade: Oh Bob no!
Bob: Ah- Oh jeez the sand ball!
Wade: AHH!
*incoherent noises*
Bob: Got ya bitch! Hey- OH SHI-
Mark and Wade: AHH!
Bob: Oh no...
Mark: CRAAAFF! CRAB! FUCKING CRABS!!
Bob: Ah!
Bob: So distracted by the god damn ball.
Bob: I didn't even shoot Mark and he was standing still.
Mark: I had crabs on me for like 10 seconds.
Bob: Yeah I had that at like the beginning of the game. It sucks!
Wade: Mark has crabs confirmed
Mark: Well whatever.
Bob: You just got to run away man.
Bob: Yeah you guys Jus-
Wade: AH THE CRABS AH NO BO-AH~H GOD!
Mark: What is this?
Bob: you guys just kill the shit out of each other.
Bob: That's fine.
Wade: Oh Crab AH.
*Mark laughing mockingly*
All: WOAH!  WHAT!!
Bob: WHAT THE FUCK.
*Wade is laughing* *Mark in shock*
Wade: I had a shark, apparently.
Bob: Whaaat?!
Mark: Whaaaat?!
*Laughter and confusion all over the place*
Wade: I didn't know!
Bob: I don't understand!
Bob: Why, why did that hi—g'oh!
Wade: AH! oh, come on.
Bob: Wow, Ah fuck you crab-No I got bitten by!-
Mark: OHHHH
Mark:OHH YES! *Weird noise by wade here*
Mark: The amount of concentration between us
Wade:*grunts*
Mark: What?
Wade: AAAH!
Bob: OH SHIT
Wade: Octupuses!
*Mark makes noises of defeat*
Wade: Ah!
Bob: Oh yes, yes!
Mark: I'ma come and get you, I'm coming for you.
Bob: Ah shit!
Bob: GOD DAMMIT!
Bob: Fuckin—Is there so- Is there some warning for that?
Wade: Yeah there's a fin goin around.
Bob: Jesus Christ *Laughs*
Wade: Stay away from the edge or people are dead.
Bob:I still don't understand.
Bob: I don't think I have ever actually-
Wade: Wh- double hit!?
Bob: WHAT THE FUCK
Mark: Two for one.
Wade: Oh, come on! No.
Bob: Oh geez!
Bob: I don't think I ever have yet-
Mark: OH NO!
*Wade laughs maniacally*
Bob: Oh wow.
Wade: Got ya!
Mark: You just got there!
Mark: Why did you spawn right there!?
Mark: That's so garbo!
Wade: It's 2 to 2 to 1!
Mark: Aww no!
Wade: I did it to Bob the first time.
Bob: I'm glad that happened to someone fucking else.
Bob: Oh Jesus! Come on!
Wade: Ah Bob!
Bob: Gotcha baby.
Wade: No no no no no.
Bob: OH THE WAVE!
Wade: Oh, that's it. I get to decide who's gonna win here.
Bob: Yeah Wade, Wade who's your friend? Who's your friend Wade?
Bob: Who's always nice to you?
Wade: Apparently that's that.
Bob: Oh, geez.
Wade: Well that was exciting.
Mark: Well alright then.
Wade: Watch out for that Beach ball.
Bob: I don't fuckin- I can't do that.
*Wade with Jaws music*
Bob: OH god!
Wade: I ate the beach ball!
*Tension rising between Mark and Bob*
Mark: *high pitched scream*
Bob: YEAHAHAHA!
*all laughing*
Wade: Man...
Bob: From behind! I land one hit!
Bob: Wade weren't you a shark? Why couldn't you just -
Wade: I ate the beach ball.
Mark: It's randomly, it's random when it hits.
Bob: so I got double sharked randomly.
Bob:Man, Mark you didn't win your match.
Mark : Shut up.
*Character laughs* *everyone joins in*
*Mark mocks it*
Mark: Alright one more, one more.
Wade: Alright, here we go.
Bob: Oh are those holes?
Bob: No they're not holes, okay.
Mark: Yeah, we're good.
Mark: Woah, drift
Bob: Oh hey I got the ball!
Bob: Oh bitches?!
Mark: What?
Mark: *high pitched* Oh come on!
Bob: Hey for once it wasn't fucking me
Mark: I- I'm gonna- I'm gonna fuck you up buddies.
Mark: Here we go, Here we go, Here it comes.
Bob: OH NO! OH GOD NO!
Bob: Why did you not take advantage of that Wade?
Wade: I didn't have the ball.
*Bob and Wade scream*
Mark: Ohahahaha!
Wade: Take that Bob- oh I missed.
Bob: What was that?
Mark: I think that's a whale.
Bob: What the fuck?
Bob: You guys just fight it out, you guys just fight it out, that's fine.
Wade: What?  What I died?!
Mark: You fell off. Don't be a whale, don't whale me bro, don't whale me.
Bob: OH NO!
Bob: GODDAMNIT!
Bob: FUCKING CHRIST!  KILL SOMEONE ELSE WHEN YOU'RE DEAD!
Bob: Jesus *Wade and Mark Dying*
Bob: Every time.
Mark: Bwahah
Mark:STOP, STO~P
Wade: You were already hurt I had to.
Mark: I was almost unhurt! I'm gonna... *mutters too quietly to hear with Wade screaming*
Mark: Come here, come here!
Wade: No he's got a whale, he's got a whale
Bob: Get him, Get him!
*all dying laughing*
Mark: You were looking at the whale, but not at the ball!
Bob: Fucking thank god it wasn't me, I was expecting the next whale
Bob: to just immediately grab for me.
*weird grunting noises*
Bob: My ball—bitch!
Bob: What!? You fuckin- It went over you!
Bob: Oh that's fine.
Bob: You guys just hang out over there and play with it by yourself
Bob: No!
Bob: Dont wanna-
All:WOAH!
Mark:NOOO!
Wade: bob BOB BOB BOAAH~
Bob: Oh no! Oh god!
Bob: AH Yes! Oh my god, were you trying to get me?
*Mark laughing*
Bob: Or were you just fucking around?
Mark: I was trying  to get both of you, you went in different drections.
Bob: I was like, Just got to kill him before mark kills me.
Bob: I know it's coming it's gonna happen.
Mark: It's not always you Wade has been dicking me over this.
Mark : Ow
Bob: Got ya
Mark: Alright you're gettin-
Mark: You're getting whaled.
Bob: God damn it.
Bob: No fuck you oil.
Mark: I'm gonna whale ya.
Bob: Oh no no no
Bob: NO! COME ON!
Mark: Oh no! Don't whale me! NO~
Wade: I can't- I can't hit you!
Mark: AH~ Bob: AH SO SLOW!
Mark: Yeah how could it, How could it-
Bob: How did I get whaled all the time?
Mark: Yeah how did you? that's really amazing.
Mark: Act~ually. Fuckin- Sto-stop! STOP!
Wade: Ahaha YEAH!
Mark:What-Ah-Fuck-I- how do you catch it?
Bob: You just have to dive into it in the air.
Bob: It's the only way I've got it.
Wade:  I've only caught one, yeah.
Wade: Well I guess Bob gets it again.
Bob: Neat *Miscellaneous noise*
Mark: uh- where- where were you shooting there?
Bob: Come on
Wade: Bob where did- Bob BOB
Bob: Oh no no nO NO NO!
Mark: Oh NOoOo!
Wade:Oh BYE BOB - OH NO
Bob: Fuck me.
Mark: NOoo~ God I hate this. So anti-climactic.
Bob: Weren't you on match point too?
Mark:Yeah he was.
Bob: God damn it.
Mark: Have I won any of these?
Bob and wade: No
Wade: It's been 2 and 2.
Wade: Would you like to record some more?  *Wade and bob dying*
Mark: Yeah, I would actually, Yeah I would!  Yes, I would!
*Wade and bob still dying*
Bob: That's the spirit!
Mark: This started off with me being good at this.
Wade: Yeah you destroyed the hard bot!
Mark: Right we're back!  We're back here in Hell where we belong!
Bob: Hell is Mark's domain.
Bob:Aw shit- How did I fuck it up-AWwah How did I miss?
Mark: Oh woah ahh.  How did i mess that up?
Bob: Yeah go in that lava wade That's good.
*Wade making sound effects*
Bob: Gotcha Bitch!
Wade: Not again!
Bob: Shit Oh why was I so slow?
Bob:Oh god
Mark: NOo~
Bob: Yeah! *Mark screams*
Wade: Bob!  I wasn't suspecting you, Bob!
Bob: Oh God NO!
Wade: Ah skeleton arm?!
Bob: How many fucking lives do you have?
Bob:Oh AURGH~
Mark: Look, we just got to get Wade, right?
Bob: How many lives do we have?
Bob: You got hit like 3 or 4 times!
Wade: It's when the stars go away you're okay.
Wade: You just have to stay alive until the stars all go away.
Bob: God damn it fucking Wade.
Wade: Ah no!
Bob: ah you hit him in to - AH NO!
Bob: No, God!
Bob:  No fucking Fuck!
Wade: AHH!  Stop, it bob!!
Wade: No not me-Ahhh!
Bob:Got him
Mark, Wade and Bob: Got him!
(Gibberish screams)
Bob:  *SCREAMS HIS HEAD OFF*
Mark: Hah!
Mark:  Okay, hang on.  Wait, I go, I gotta go get it.
Bob:  No, why didn't you-
Mark: *Dreams Of Winning*
Mark:  God dammit.
Mark: YEAHHH
Bob: God, fucking shit!
Bob: My guy doesn't turn like that.
Bob: When I try and turn, it never turns before I shoot it.
Mark: Oh I don't know.
Wade:That's weird.
Bob:I think I'm just bad at timing.
Bob: Ah worth it.
Bob: WHAT...did you push me in?!
Mark: I don't know?
Bob: I didn't...I didn't go in that time.
Wade: Aah a rock!!
Bob: What??
Mark: Aww c'mon I dived for that.
All Three: *Scream* Yah!
Wade: no!
Bob: I'm Fucking with wade.
Bob: Im fucking with wade.
Wade: Why! Aah skeleton arms!!
Mark: Grab em!
Bob: Hey come get the balls bitches!
Mark: Nooo!
Bob: Come get the fucking ball, bitches!
Mark: No~
Wade: No
Mark: No.
Mark: No!
Bob: Oh, my god.  That was a bold dive.
Mark: *almost says SANTA?* What Now- -aww
Bob: Awww
Mark: You can just push people.
Mark: You can push people. (x2)
I might win! Guys!
Wade + Mark: Oh No no no
Bob: What??
Bob: Wait, get him, get him.
Wade: I'm trying.
Mark: Don't get me, why get me?
Bob: How was that working together?
Wade: oh, Idon't know.  I wasn't paying attention to who I was fighting.
Wade: Ow
Mark: Hahaha
Bob: Like I would save you.
Wade: alright Bob, I'm working with you.
Bob: God, dammit.
Mark: *Screams Again* No, you guys are assholes!
Mark:  Do it!
Mark: Fucking do it!
Mark: Fucking do it!!!!!
Bob:Alright
Mark: AWH~ FUCKIn do it.
BOB: AH WADE?!
Mark: GOD YES YES WOAAAH~
Wade: I thought I hit him.
*CLAPS FOR DAYS*
Bob:You're the worst teammate!
Mark:Ah~ Yes!
Bob: Jesus Christ!
Mark:  He's Got a M on his shirt!
Wade: Show me how you really feel.
Bob: You only hit me(X2)
Mark: YAASSS!
Wade: My angel played on him.
Mark: Okay we can end there.
Bob:  Great, cut out the round Mark won.
Mark: Noo don't do that!
Mark: Make it seem like I won every round.
Wade: That gonna take a lot of work.
*giggling*
Mark: Play the round normally,
Mark: then after they win just have me go
Mark: WOOOOOAAH
Mark: That was so fun, my God.
Bob: Ah, Christ.
Mark: That was a crazy game.
Mark: But anyway, thank you everybody so much for watching.
Mark: This was way more fun than I thought it would be and way more competitive
Mark: So thank you, Bob and Wade for joining me.
Mark: Hope your voice are okay.
Bob: Nope, it's trashed.
Wade: *Tiny screech*
Mark:
Yeah, but I hope you enjoyed us Le-Moo
Mark: I hope you enjoyed IT.
Mark: Let us know what you
thought of it in the comments below.
and check ou- *funky noise* their channels in the description
Thanks again everybody for watching.
And as always,
I will see you
*Wade imitates funky noise*
in the next video.
Buh-Bye!
Wade: "Check out their-*funky noise*"
*Laughing*